we'll see the second start wearing the
birds on the bat for left-hander
john lester looking forward to this
ricky yeah i've been
looking forward to this outing and i
know he is as well
you know lester is a guy that's closing
in on 200 career victories and
wouldn't that be something if he was
able to do that in the cardinal uniform
whitmerfield does have a base hit in
this series and now a fly ball to
right fielder dylan carlson two out long
and it brings in carlos santana the
cleanup hitter
popped up right side goldie
over and out of play one and two
well goldschmidt caught it he sure did
he's right there
unfortunately it was the wrong one and
the one ball two-strike delivery now by
the cardinal left-hander just headed
home swinging the ground ball to the
shark stop
and the fourth out of the second is good
four or six
[Applause]
[Music]
but you know what though but she's up
for the challenge let's hope that he can
find his stuff early
and not give them any runs because the
royals have really had a hard time
winning games and they'd fall behind
you can see that his pitch selection
right here or his arsenal fourth this
three pitches
forcing fastball it sets up to change up
in the curve dylan carlson i mentioned
it earlier ricky but he's played in just
about every
inning this year in the air
left center well hit taylor back at the
wall
gone lead off homer
dylan carlson and it's one-nothing
st louis the second career leadoff homer
for the rookie
now goldschmidt paul hitting 269.
now curve in there there's the curveball
gotta use it
one down for oronato it's a smash up the
middle diving stop by merrifield throw
to first and he got him
from merrifield takes a hit away from
gold glover arenado
knows all about very good defensive
plays and bear field
as a gem right there that ball was
really smoked
that brings up tommy edmond tommy
hitting 255.
well he strikes out tommy edmond
but gives up a home run to the lead-off
batter dylan carlson for a one-nothing
st
louis lead the cardinals have their lead
off man on base
it brings up pauldie young ground ball
third they've got one whit with a nice
turn
wow how about that not surprise i was
just getting ready to say put him in the
lane bubic
induces his 15th ground ball double play
of the year kisner hit his first
home run of the year the other night
against atlantic
and there is strike three call kind of
locked him up
is out 6-3 and there are two down in the
third
and here comes merrifield back up the
middle that's a base hit
number 118 for merrifield this year
that's right catch that one and that'll
bring up nikki lopez lopez fly to right
his first time up
fly ball into left center
and the catch made by bader john lester
leads things off here for the cardinals
at the bottom of the third
out to center it's well hit taylor back
over his head and it's a ground rule
double for
jon lester and his first saint louis
cardinals base hit
a little thunder 104 off the bat in
there now
two down and it'll be up to nolan ornato
3-2
sends it into center field that ball is
down they're going to hold up
lester and runners at the corners
and a chance for tyler o'neill
nikki lopez the short way and a good job
by boobage to get out of a third inning
jam
so as we get set it'll be salvador perez
leading things off
and there's a swing and a miss and a
strikeout for leicester michael a
taylor has the best numbers with him
loaded on the royals
head sharply to right base hit and come
santana the royals have tied it at one
on a solid base hit by michael a taylor
and that was a great at-bat the bases
are still loaded with one out and here's
hanser alberto
to third they got one and safe at first
and the royals take the lead as dozier
scores yeah
way to get out of the box so now 2-1
with chris
bubich at the plate up the middle
again and the young is there steps on
the bag
lester gives up a pair and the royals
grab a lead it's 2-1
but now the cardinals have two walks and
a hit batter and they're loaded up with
nobody out
to kisner and here it comes and a
breaking ball is grounded back to [ __ ]
he'll go to the plate for one
salvy to first for two one two three
and now it's second and third two down
for lester let him hit it
he does
and pops him up alberto takes care of it
you talk about walking the razor's edge
and not cutting yourself
wow 90 feet from home plate the batter
will be salvador perez
orlando knocks that one to left the
catch will be made by tyler o'neal his
throw home
is not going to be in time and now skips
away from kisner but the royals take a
3-1 lead on perez's
69th rbi this year goldschmidt is struck
out looking
and fly to right right-handed hitting
first baseman
oh beauty good change up there and he
gets
goldsmith to swing and miss and strikes
him out so
second and third two out the batter is
edmond
edmond lifts it high in the air left
side
olivares makes the catch and the
cardinals have
left five runners stranded in the last
two innings unable to advance
dozier to third see if michael a taylor
can pick him up here
taylor whacks that one to left field
dozier
will be held at third base oh oh and now
he'll
come and he'll race home and the royals
take a
four to one lead
on the base hit the error that will also
advance taylor to second base
taylor stays at third the royals now
hoping that ryan o'hearn can get a
clutch
two-out base hit hit well to right field
that's a base hit and a clutch
two out hit by o'hearn pushes the royals
in front
five to one two up two down that'll
bring in carlos santana santana
is one for three on the afternoon
tough play arenado backhands jump throw
and got him
wow nolan aronado don't get tired of
that
that'll bring in paul goldschmidt base
hit
that'll cut the lead to five to two as
goldie
drives in his 62nd run first hit of the
afternoon
brings in rondon 5-2 our score bases
loaded
one out dylan carlson who is homer today
coming up
and carlson lifts a high fly ball into
right
over to get it will be dozier makes the
catch two runners tag
up and that'll make it a 5-3 game
and that'll bring up paul goldsmith
goldie bass heading to right
that makes it five to four that brings
in
kisner the time run in scoring position
and it brings in nolan aronado
little flare into shallow center it may
drop it will
the game is tied nolan comes through
five five first
and third with o'neal the batter
he finally gets the slider across but
the cardinals score
three to tie-in alberto singles and that
will bring up dyson
gets the bunt down fielded by goldsmith
and he throws it away
alberto's gonna make it to third and
dice into second and with that
with the rain coming down the tarp is
gonna go on the field
so they call the players off the field
with runners at second and third
here in the ninth inning well welcome
back everyone we're about to start
baseball again
second and third infield in nobody out
in the ninth
win mere field at the plate ground ball
hit to short play at the plate
and he is out out at the plates
so the royals end up with dyson at third
era field will be at first
nikki lopez will come to bat
hit sharply into right field in comes
dyson and the royals have
a six to five lead on the clutch base
hit by nikki lopez
they're two out so carlos santana steps
in one
two swung on and missed can they come
back one more time in this game
two big ouch for love lady and now paul
de young
in their strike three call and richard
lovelady has his first
major league c save and it comes in the
i-70 series